this is the only footage that has
emerged from inside the amarillo hotel
where up to 200 people have reportedly
taken refuge as the town of palmer
remains under siege for a fifth day by
an armed group
hundreds of people have attempted to
flee the town running into forests and
nearby villages
we don't know how we will get out of
here if we can get to the sea
or if we'll be rescued or by whom there
are helicopters flying over the hotel
they're checking to see if we can reach
the beach to get a boat out
but as you can hear we don't know if
it's possible
the situation is critical we have no
food just water
we're in god's hands now
gun battles have been ongoing for days
between the armed group that calls
itself al-shabab
and government forces trying to take
back control of the coastal town
fighting started in northern mozambique
in 2017 by armed groups
mainly in cabo delgado province that's
where most of the major gas discoveries
have been made in recent years
but the town of palmer had been
relatively safe for foreigners working
on africa's largest liquefied natural
gas project
until this week the french energy giant
total has now evacuated a thousand of
its workers
and suspended its operations it was due
to restart a 20 billion dollar project
this week after stopping work in january
because of security concerns years of
fighting in cabo delgado has left more
than 2
500 people dead and forced more than
half a million people
to leave their homes it's really a toxic
mix of various issues it is a province
the northernmost province of mozambique
that is marginalized
people feel frustrated they have been
um people thrown off their land
of mining activities their ruby mines
specifically and then uh when it was
announced that
the biggest investment on the african
continent these last few decades
were going to come to cabo delgado the
swing almost
the um you know it it exploded
amnesty international blames several
parties for war crimes committed during
the conflict
it has accused armed groups as well as a
government-backed private south african
military firm
for the deaths of hundreds of civilians
it also says government troops have
arrested civilians without reason
tortured detainees and carried out
extrajudicial killings
there are reports of boats taking those
escaping the fighting
to the provincial capital pemba but as
the conflict continues
the united nations is warning of even
more internal displacement
zara al jazeera